hi my name is Charlie day and I feel
euphoric about being Conor O'Brien's
very best friend in the entire universe
well wait a minute
improvise a little better but yeah I
might I'll let me do it on book no no I
that was good I like I I like that one I
like that you're my very my very best
friend uh I just said Barry best friend
yeah
you heard it right we've all been
drinking and it's early in the day
um I'm delighted you're here I'm
thrilled to be here someone just
reminded me that you did the Late Night
show a bunch of times or
some incarnation of one of the shows but
I think nine times yeah which I say is
too many
yeah that shows a neediness on your but
you kept having me in and uh which I
appreciate it yeah uh to get to I know
we're ready for the jokes we want to get
into it full seriousness uh my absolute
favorite talk show ever to be on I think
you were the first one if it wasn't the
first one I did it was the first one
that I felt like I did correctly oh
um because uh in my mind you were you're
my Johnny Carson oh that's sweet top of
the mountain top and now that you've
quit I resent you
and I'm I'm forced to do every all the
other people all the Lesser then oh well
that's very sweet of you to say it's so
funny because my introduction to It's
Always Sunny in Philadelphia was uh Sona
my Earth while assistant coming in and
screaming at me did you see it's always
sunny last night and I say no I I didn't
see it last night you know I didn't see
end
um uh her just her whole you know what I
used to do at the Late Night show was
make sure the way Stalin did that there
were images of me everywhere yes you
know magazine covers and everything was
Conan and then you'd get to sona's part
of the office and it was all it's always
sunny yeah just pretty much that whole
area it was a lot of pain there's fun
pictures like promo pictures and stuff
but yeah you're making me sound kind of
crazy but yeah but you also you have
great comedic taste
you were right about uh and and I always
I always felt that you your gang that
you have this I don't know similar
philosophy about making people laugh
that made me very happy which was just
this things could get very anarchic and
crazy but the show never really took
itself very seriously and still hasn't
and
um and there was just a pure raw we're
going to have fun and
um and make fools of ourselves if need
be I think we're in the business uh the
very serious business of how ridiculous
can we be yeah which isn't as easy as
just saying okay let's go goof off like
well
put an extraordinary amount of work and
thought and conversation into the most
ridiculous thing yes yes but the passion
and Care is there also uh we may have
learned a lot of this from you you may
be partly responsible well that's the
point I'm getting to I think there's a
cut of the of the royalties yeah yeah no
talk to Robin Glenn because I think that
I'm sure I'll get very far yeah um it's
a funny dichotomy that I talk to people
about which is I am two things very
silly and I love abstract foolishness
taken to its extreme and I'm also deadly
deadly serious about it and you
understand that the two things coexist
because I think there are a lot of
people who think oh the Always Sunny
guys if you you know if you hung out in
their writer's room if you hung out with
them it's just Clowning all the time and
I know for a fact that no there are
probably very very heated arguments yeah
about how the really stupid things
should happen we we got in one this year
16 years into doing the show and a good
sort of heated debate about this is the
way to do it and this is the way to do
we do it every single it's exhausting
it's exhausting but it's all that sort
of arguing and planning so that you can
have that you know 15 minutes of just
raw funny which is like oh we all agree
that this is the best scenario for
something to be funny and now just let
it rip because we feel sort of safe like
we've built up the work around it and
here's a playground with which to
destroy sandcastles yeah
well we have um going back we have a
bunch of things in common you grew up in
Rhode Island I did and I kind of grew up
in Rhode Island because explain
yeah one foot in Rhode Island I used to
drive there every night and spend an
hour at a on a dock yeah and a fisherman
from childhood every day it was an
important my dad insisted
um
yeah I'm from uh from from Massachusetts
from Brookline right outside Boston and
then uh we didn't have a summer house
growing up and we would go and stay at
my grandfather's house which was in
Misquamicut Rhode Island right next to
the State Beach sure so we were uh you
know he was a retired policeman we would
hang out at his house and then walk down
to the State Beach and
um I would hang around Rhode Island and
sometimes we would hang around there for
a month to two months in the summer okay
and so uh I got a really good dose of
the Rhode Island Vibe and uh I have to
say I mean it's funny because it's a
very strong accent people complain about
the Boston accent the Rhode Island
accent you start to tip into New York
and Rhode Island where it kind of mashes
the two yeah and my favorite is I once
stopped in Cranston Rhode Island
Cranston and I got out of my uh car to
fill up my tank of gas and I had my hat
on just to try and like I just wanna
this is you know years and years into
late night show I'm just gonna fill up
with gas and this woman like in an acid
wash jacket got out of her Jeep and she
walked up to me and she was giving me
the look like you can't hide from me and
she went I spotted yeah I spotted yeah
you think you're a big shot now huh yeah
yeah and I thought man that's Cranston
Rhode Island yeah Cranston especially is
pretty thick I would get a lot I'd go
home and I get a lot of that uh one of
my friends uh fathers he's a is a
carpenter in Rhode Island uh Portuguese
Rhode Island tough as nails and uh
I'd start coming home and he'd say uh
what's up Kevin and I started thinking
oh no it's starting to is peach starting
his nickname was peach peach starting to
lose it a little bit
and then I realized he was calling me
Kevin because he started calling me uh
Here Comes Costner so so
just because you had had success yes you
are now Kevin Costner
and an actor to him is only Kevin
Costner actors and acting stocks that's
hilarious heck of course not ah Here
Comes Costner like man I go should I
wash my car for a room or with it but
yeah so Kevin Costner is where actors
beginning that's hilarious yeah yeah
yeah yeah I uh yeah
and if something's good he has a
language of his own this guy's language
is also something's good it's clean so
it was like uh you know right now he'd
probably if I saw me be like I heard
that uh Super Mario Brothers pretty big
that's clean brother
yeah clean is good clean is positive and
uh you know if it came out in Tanked
he'd be like I saw your movie Suspect
clean and suspect clean and suspect are
they chew that's the only two words
yeah well that sums up Rhode Island for
you yeah that is hilarious yeah I uh
yeah there there is something
um because I
was in Westerly you know do you know the
town of Westerly at all and I was in
Westerly Rhode Island and this was about
I don't know like eight years ago when I
was with my mom and my brother Neil and
we were in this restaurant it was a
Portuguese kind of Italian restaurant
and we're in there and we're having our
meal and the waitress recognized me and
I could see her looking at me and then
she she went out back and I guess made a
phone call and then she came out in this
very thick accent that I can't really do
but she was like I talked to the manager
and he's here's the deal if you would
come back and and do two days
of like uh signing autographs and we
could tell we could uh
could publicize it you know Conan
O'Brien's gonna be here and he's going
to do two days he's gonna sign
autographs and you greet everyone at
their table if you could do that for two
days dinner's on us
so how'd it go for real
dinner's on us and I was just thinking
like I so want to call
my representation in Los Angeles and get
them involved and you know they'll be
saying things like wait a minute no uh
you're gonna send a plane right no no
but Dennis included how much parmesan
yeah yeah how much parmesan yeah and you
know that and I know that these people
would win these people would defeat my
representation a 12 bowl of Clans
is on us we just want two entire days of
your time yeah two days it was two days
which I thought was really weird like
really in two days yeah you got a two
two days for one meal also I know that
some people would come the first day and
then no one would come the second day
like you know you'd pretty much meet
everyone that would want to say hi to me
in one day and do you get a free video
each day or is it just one for the they
said dinner's on us they said singular
dinner yeah so I don't think I get a
dinner the first night but I do get it
the second night wow or maybe I get it
the second night and not the I mean the
first night but not the second night who
knows that's a real win-win for them you
know uh all the diversity and I screwed
up you should have done it